have you ever wondered what happens when
someone in England visits the world
science festivals webpage first their
computer needs to ask the world science
festival server for a copy of that
webpage the computer sticks this request
into a virtual envelope called a packet
wrapped with specific information about
that request including the world science
festivals IP address the computer sends
this packet out of the house and below
the street via large underground copper
wires it passes through small regional
networks before ending up here at tella
house north in London tella house north
is England's main internet hub the IP
address on this packet tells the hub
that the world science festival server
is actually in Los Angeles so tella
house north sends the packet out as
light across the Atlantic over fibre
optic cables very deep beneath the ocean
the packet ends up here 60 Hudson Street
New York City the largest Internet hub
on the East Coast
this hub sends the packet through a
series of regional networks connecting
New York to Los Angeles where the world
science festival server resides the
server reads the requests and gets ready
to send the webpage to England but web
pages made up of images and text are too
large to send us a single packet of data
so how do we get it back to England
imagine a group of 5,000 tourists
visiting New York City in a single
gigantic tour bus they are way up in
Harlem but they want to visit the Statue
of Liberty before it closes
but it's rush hour on a Friday there's
no way that giant bus is going to fit
through those crazy congested streets so
they decide to get off the bus and
spread out some take the subway some
take cabs a few rent bikes and some even
take kayaks down the Hudson River how
they get there doesn't matter as long as
they get there on time
likewise for the internet to work
efficiently this webpage is pulverized
into thousands of tiny packets of data
each one racked with all of the
information that needs to rebuild itself
in England the packets are sent to LA is
one Wilshire hub which checks the
traffic report before sending them off
through miles and miles of Lam they
travel checking in through different
hubs like our New York City tourists
those packets don't care how they get
there as long as they get there as fast
as possible most of them will go through
60 Hudson in New York where they are
redirected back to England as light
riding a fibre of glass as thick as a
silver dollar then back on copper wire
through regional British networks until
all the package reach their destination
and and this epic journey it all happens
in about a second along with trillions
upon trillions of similar journeys that
happen each and every day on this
remarkable easy to take for granted
network of networks we call the Internet
[Music]
yeah